I think one of the sad things, but the reality is over the past 20,
25 years is the Republicans have shown themselves to be very good at winning
elections. Maybe not in this particular case for the white house,
but in general, they win elections and very bad at fighting the culture Wars.
And it's unfortunate because now the Democrats control the
media, Hollywood academia, big tech,
and half the country doesn't feel represented at all in
almost all of the information that comes back to them publicly.
What do you think.
The big tech element then also that, you know,
going forward that at least, even though they did nothing, I mean,
I kept saying this the whole time you guys are having these hearings and it's
great to see Ted Cruz who I totally like and respect.
It's great to see him grill Jack,
but you guys are doing it six days before an election.
And we're pretending that this is in theater. Are you worried that okay,
Trump was sort of the last thing that was stopping big tech from doing whatever
it might want to do. I don't know what exactly what it wants to do,
but now without that threat of we're going to regulate you, whatever it might,
you know, break you up, stuff that I don't particularly want them to do. Uh,
are you worried that they're just going to go all in and,
and silence the real resistance, which will be the remaining freethinkers?
Yes, I am worried about that. I don't have the solution to that either. I,
I am worried. I think one of the sad things,
but the reality is over the past 20,
25 years is the Republicans have shown themselves to be very good at winning
elections. Maybe not in this particular case for the white house,
but in general, they win elections and very bad at fighting the culture Wars.
And it's unfortunate because now the Democrats control the
media Hollywood, um, academia,
big tech and half the country doesn't feel represented at
all in almost all of the information that comes back to them publicly,
like sports forgot to mention them.
So you turn on the television and watch a sports game or get the news or watch
the Oscars or the VMs, whatever it is.
And now you're getting woke is shoved down your neck.
And you're being told you're a racist. If you happen to be a Republican,
you like Trump, or even just,
if you're a Republican these days and you send out a tweet that is
totally legitimate and maybe just opinionated or a news story being
reported by that New York post censored, censored, censored, you know,
your viewpoints or you're being told they're bad by everyone that has control of
the public microphones. And I do think at least people could be like, Hey,
am I insane? And is everything. I think
it's a problem. Now I think big tech is part of the problem.
I really wish we would see somebody like Peter teal, you know, who, you know,
he's going to, to actively create a new Twitter and a new Facebook. And like,
there needs to be a real,
other digital forum out there that represents the other half of the country.
Cause I just don't think they've got much of a future on the existing platforms.
Well,
the irony is if Trump loses and then it finally gives him the impetus to be
like, okay, I'm going to another platform or I'm starting my own platform.
That's how the platform will work. Right? Like that ultimately would be it. No,
you don't, you don't think that would be enough.
No, I think that'll be like, I mean, with all due respect,
Sean Hannity starting his own network, like, you know,
you know what you're going to get.
You're not going to get real analysis that now that's.
Well, I don't mean, I don't mean you'll get analysis. I mean,
if Trump is just like, all right, I'm going,
I'm going to parlor or I'm going to locals or wherever that it would be like
everyone would go there just because he's still the show in a way.
I don't mean that he's going to create some non-partisan network.
You can not like conservative media is well-represented in the digital world.
I get that. But when it comes to these main, the main platforms out there,
when it, I mean, Facebook is, it gives a little bit more play, but they're,
they're censoring a lot of stuff too. But if you could have a real,
and I know there's parlor, I'm on parlor, but it's just,
it's not what Twitter is. And I don't know that it's going to be,
you need a real player with a lot of money to,
to create the platform and back it. And somebody with a spine of steel,
like Rupert Murdoch to say, I don't need to be loved at the cocktail parties.
I'm going to let this be a real forum for mainstream conservative
thought. In other words, we don't need Alex Jones on there. Okay.
But like Dave Rubin does not need to get censored. Right.
And I that's my only thought because I,
you're not going to change Jack Dorsey. You're not going to change Facebook.
You're not going to change these big tech organizations for whom it's like
deeply ideological. They think it's the difference between good and evil.
You know, it's not just about getting Biden, elected.
It's about silencing the rest of these resists.
Did you see that clip from sunny Hostin on the view? Yeah.
Unbelievable.
That that embodies how they think that the left wing and I don't even mean
progressive. I know you used to be one.
Most professors I know are totally normal and mainstream and they don't believe
in any of this nonsense.
It's the quote left with a capital L who are insane and the way they see the
other half of the country and sunny Hostin,
just put it on display where it was like these at least half the
country. I'm not going to say they're racists. Yeah, whatever it is,
that's either racist. But at least half the country voted for him.
Net was standing his racism, his sexism, racism,
xenophobia has transphobia.
And then another woman on the panel, Sarah, I don't remember her name,
but she was like, how can you say that? You know, people vote in their own.
Self-interest all the time, pocket book issues. And so on.
It doesn't make them bad. It doesn't make them racist.
And the response was no, because this is about we,
the people and we are supposed to behave as a collective and do what
is right. It's one of those things day. I was like, Oh my God, I wish so badly.
For the first time in my life that I were sitting on the view,
I would have loved to said to her, I get it. Totally. And just out of curiosity,
I'm wondering, cause like there's a lot of people who really feel like,
for example, um,
abortion is murder and it's actually killing babies and that's wrong.
And what would be right would be to ban it outright.
And if you don't support that, you are on the wrong side,
you're in favor of murder. And we,
the people respond to you to behave as a collective, right?
Like I could go on for, you know, give me five other examples, like eat outrage.
And by the way, let's look at the Southern border. You know,
the people down there who have had family members killed by people illegally
coming across with drugs and weapons who have lost jobs to people who are here
unlawfully in the country.
They have real reasons for wanting a great border wall and for cracking down on
illegal immigration. And if you don't support it,
you're the one who doesn't care about life and the well-being of your fellow
citizens and read the people who died and made her
King of we, the people. Right.
So do you think,
do you think they'll ever stop that thing like that in many ways,
what you just described there? That is the thing that most,
the rest of us are fighting to make it about Sonny, but that thing,
and it's been so successful and,
and as we're talking potentially is about to dethrone Donald Trump,
why would they stop doing it?
They're not going to, they're not going to. And I,
I agreed with the headlines this week that said woke ism was Delta blow during
this election because he saw, you know, his numbers.
As you pointed out with all these minority groups, go up, people,
the minority groups like him more than they used to,
not less like four years of ubiquitous media coverage,
telling them he's awful racist, bigot, all this stuff.
And that they're awful if they like it. So that didn't work. Oh. And by the way,
I mean, even just today, there was a Congressman,
a democratic Congresswoman who was saying, uh, defund,
the police killed us, killed us.
That is why we went down in the house instead of up.
And if we don't abandon that ridiculous messaging,
we're going to see a bloodbath in two years. So woke is, um, you know,
that the messaging was proven to be a failure when it comes to electoral
politics, but that won't deter them. That's not going to stop anything.
But for the reasons I was saying, it's ideological,
it makes them feel like better people. So, um,
I don't know if it's their guilt,
if it's just the virtue signaling makes them feel great about themselves in bed
at night when they judge other people and decide they're all bad.
So we're going to have to deal with it.
And the people who don't believe in this BS culture,
and there's so many people in the center, right,
who don't either look at the Harper's Le leather letter,
look at people like Andrew Sullivan who hated Trump, but you know,
he's completely taken a stand against this baloney.
They're going have to speak up. They're the people who are against it.
I know they're afraid.
I know you can get fired now for the most ridiculous reasons. Trust me, I know
we're going to have to start taking risks. Otherwise we're all going to go down.
You know, we're going to go down together on this war.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about the media,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our media playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out the full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.